you guys had a daughter we had a
daughter very recently
you should have yeah you should have
been a little quicker with the applause
on that a lot of crowds will immediately
applaud you guys ice-cold I like yeah
yeah yeah my first Father's Day Sunday
it's my first that's exciting that's
exciting I think I saw in an interview
or something you said that you were
pressured by other parents to have other
parents your age to have kids you felt
pressure from them well that's for sure
true and it they definitely parents
become evangelical when they have kids
they're like you got to do it you got to
do it there's an extra love that you
don't know about yet you know it's like
you're in to deal of land and there's 40
love those same people they're like that
extra chamber of love you got to do the
day after I had the child we're like
welcome to
they don't tell you that why where were
you 24 hours ago it's like this ultimate
bait and switch but we're very happy yes
help me she's awesome she's cute she's
verbal she loves the show I do very well
very well with three and four month olds
do you do you find it I mean it's you
find it to be difficult you're being a
new dad such a young baby Herenton yeah
not it no it's very easy no really no
it's a lot of people talk about like how
difficult it is and all the parents are
like how are you sleeping how are you
sleeping sleeping is so easy when you
have a newborn you just you go to sleep
and then when the baby wakes up the lady
who sleeps next to you goes and takes
care of the baby 50% of the audience
applauding the other 50% not into that
joke
then in the morning you go you have
coffee with your buddies go surfing you
come home she's alive everything's good
you set yourself a real bar I know
you're a good dad I know that you're
involved thank you I love her she's
great you actually you're your wife
Natasha posted a picture of you caring
for your your daughter this your
standard what do you think is the
difference I mean clearly there is a
difference between how the man reacts
and the woman reacts well I you know a
lot of people say that I mean like a lot
of people are upset about like Natasha
posted that picture which was I thought
a deep deep violation of the privacy of
our home and
when people are like oh you know this is
this is why men are bad at parenting but
it's not true like women have hormonal
you know chemicals flooding through them
that are saying like take care of this
child take care of this child like a
nobody talks about how difficult it is
for men who have none of those chemicals
to just stick around at all it is for me
to not pack up a little hobo sack and
just hit the road you know you know that
raccoon that was climbing up that tower
yesterday yeah that was a male raccoon
shirking his parental
you